[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul and this video we're
breaking down the boys spin-off series
gen V the first look has a lot of
references to the show including nods to
homelander an appearance by a train and
Ashley along with a puppet of the deep
in this video we're gonna be going in
deep a and talking about the show the
new characters and things that we think
will be happening in the series gen V is
basically going to be an X-Men parody
with several teenage kids being trained
as superheroes in order to become the
next big soups the title gen V is of
course a play on gen Z Vaught and also
chemical V however I actually think
there might be a duplicate to it that
links back to the X-Men back in 1996
there was a live-action X-Men show
released called Generation X that got
shown on Channel 5 in the UK I had my
tape all set up to record it and the
next day realized I'd set the wrong time
so I never got to see it stuck with me
though and has finally paid off by
appearing in this video thank God
welcome to Good olken University
it's a safe space for you to thrive now
this opening instantly sets up where the
show will be taking place that is good
Elkin University and fans of the comics
will instantly recognize the name John
godalkin was the leader of the G-men and
he was a sort of Professor X Type bigger
that pulled together lots of soups to
form the group he had his own mansion
out in the countryside and similar to
Xavier this school for gifted youngsters
trained several of them I think that's
likely what's going to be going on here
with us potentially even meeting the
character at some point in the series
kedulkin has a darker side to him and in
the comics we learned that he was
abusing the students Huey infiltrated
the group disguised as a soups and he
slowly start to inert the Celia side to
it which is also something that ball
became aware of in the end godelken went
to set his students on the boys but
soldiers from board arrived and they
wiped them out along with godalkin
they'd become aware of what he was doing
and didn't want the pr disaster that was
bound to come from this getting out now
the comic was written way before the
metoo movement and it is possible that
it could be tied in with that or they
might just not choke at Oakland at all
if he is in the series I can see him
possibly being played by Clancy Brown
however he may be someone who worked
with board and on Earth the truth he
does look a bit disheveled he he's
pulling a gun on someone as if he's
being very suspicious on who they are
and he might not be good olkin but if if
they have cast him then yeah that's
gonna be who it is now the teaser opens
with the school of crime fighting and to
the left of the entrance we can see a
statue for Lamplighter Lamplighter was
replaced by Starlight in season one and
we were told that he had retired whether
he'd actually been shipped after the
sagegrove center which is where he was
freed in season two Lamplighter ended
his own life by setting himself on fire
and bought Tower but the fact that this
statue is here makes me think that it
was hidden from the public but would
have a habit of covering up the deaths
of their soups and they used to run
cover stories to hide what really
happened with them the statue for him
being here hints that it's all been
swept under the rug and lamplighter's
reputation hasn't gone down in flames Eh
this in transitions into Marie Moreau
looking about one for Homeland air when
we last saw him he was about to start
his Kanye Dolph Hitler Rock and he'd
murdered someone at a rally to Rapture
us Applause he is still votes number one
Money Maker though with a very loyal
following so the company probably hasn't
got rid of him yet however there is also
the potential that this could be a
prequel to The Show and that takes us
into
Moodle
now we're unsure of when the series is
taking place as there are some things in
this that Hint it could be a prequel or
something that's happening alongside
season 3. there's a nod to black noir
and though he died in season three we do
know the mantle will be taken up by
someone else due to him wearing a mask
his murder could go undetected and this
school might actually end up setting up
a training program that selects who the
next one's gonna be big Theory time yeah
but there are ways around this now the
Deep puppet is girls out too which was
only brought into the public once the
show had started so I am thinking it
takes place either as season 3 is
unfolding or just after it Marie Moreau
unfortunately isn't from the comics
either so we can't even really use her
to judge when about it's happening
however she has showed up in the series
before with us actually getting a
picture of her in the Red River files
when investigating Victoria Newman Huey
and starlight came across a list of Red
River students and slap bang in the
middle was Marie M really nice touch
placing their main character in season
three and as of been saying it's all
connected now later on in the teaser we
see Marie standing in a room and to the
left and right of her are signs for the
location there's blood lining the walls
and potentially we'll be seeing her
training her powers here according to
the wiki Marie has powers which are very
very Loosely based around Wolverine as
she possesses Vain and arteries
manipulation which means that she can
fire them out of her wrists allowing
them to latch onto people but Kevin how
is that like Wolverine well Timmy Marie
has a regenerative healing factor and
Harissa turn open when she's using her
abilities when her veins go back in the
wrists heal themselves similar how
Wolverine's claws retract I'm guessing
that this also stops people from just
cutting her veins and killing her pretty
easily I actually think she might try
and end her own life in the show as we
see her pulling out a pocket knife after
the Red River shot again on the floor we
can see a sign for Red River it looks
like we're going to be exploring this
location very very in depth it popped up
in the boy's diabolical and it was a
horrendous place where people got EXP
experimented on in order to improve
their powers we cruised the corridors of
the school and to the left hand side we
can see a vending machine selling a
trains turbo Rush after this we go to
the words murderer which are Written in
Blood but appears throughout the teaser
and it's a motif that pops up at several
different points
blood blood
and bits of sick obviously Marie has
powers that link in with her blood and
I'm guessing that she becomes the
suspect in the murders that we see
playing out I even have a theory that
someone might have similar powers to
Victoria Newman and they could be
ripping people apart in the next shot we
see someone's eyes opening widely with
them looking extremely bloodshot this
could either be a victim or the killer
themselves starting up their powers
couldn't the SWAT team going through a
school again symbolizing that these have
to be pretty high level crimes we then
jump to a picture of a cartoon bunny
rabbit somewhat echoing the visions that
black noir used to have a SWAT team
member also patrols the corridor hitting
at how this might be an ongoing thing as
more matters happen the black SWAT team
members are hammered home by the black
noir sign which says no lucky lose and
then this area is patrolled by security
we then see a shot of someone crying and
blood running into a train from here we
get Adam Burke the director of dawn of
the seven what do you mean it was really
Tony Gilroy now he also does a chef's
kiss gesture and also had a bit of a
thing with Ashley who two appears later
on in the trailer from here we get an
upside down shot of a girl in her dorm
room standing in the middle of the room
the way this pans around and how she
looks at the camera makes me think that
this might be the person carrying out
the murders who's just found the next
victim she looks shocked to see whatever
this is and yeah that's what I'm going
with I keep mentioning the serial killer
theme it's not being confirmed yet might
not be part of the show and if you think
there's something else going on then let
me know because I'm going fully down the
rabbit hole on this I'll stop with that
now as it is getting in the way and in
what's a nice little Easter egg we can
see a queen made poster hanging up on
the wall we then get some quick shots of
some characters that I'm unsure of who
exactly they are before we see a train
in the flesh he's rocking a cap but the
seven is wearing a suit and is also
clearly about to give a speech I think
he might potentially be opening a newing
of the school or doing something along
those lines that require is his
appearance nice detail on the mic is
that we can see the news network BSN is
covering it which is obviously owned by
vort though I'm saying this is a school
it could also possibly be happening at
board Tower as we can see Windows behind
him that have those criss-crossing
diagonal lines on them this is similar
to what they have in the tower so
potentially this scene comes from there
it could even be the moment where they
announced the new seven members as their
numbers were whittled down massively
after the events of season three it's
also possible that this is a flashback
in which we see a train getting drafted
into the group it sort of has an NFL
style to it and this might be used as
promotional material at the school to
show look it look what you can become if
you get another seven you can hate your
life just like a train does look what
you can become now after the shot of
Clancy Brown we get several different
scenes that are clearly at a medical
facility you can tell by the tiled walls
and infrastructure that this is
somewhere else where it seems like
they're carrying out experiments we see
blood and guts being swept up with a
character covered in blood similar to
Victoria back back to the murder Theory
yeah I said I wouldn't do but
potentially this could be someone
carrying out their powers which are
similar to Vex and this is why there's
blood and guts everywhere it clearly
weren't harmed as their cupboard in it
and it could be a splashback from their
victim and there's also a character
being carried along the hallway and I
have seen people saying that because
they were in the blue patient clothing
that this could be the sage Grove Center
however I actually just think this is
Red River and that will be focused on
learning the backstory of that rather
than it being Sage so I'm taking your
theory time I'm bringing back the murder
one and I'm telling you to put yours in
the [ __ ] bin and [ __ ] off go [ __ ]
yourself
now amongst these moments we get a
montage of students along with my man
Ambrose from chilling Adventures of
Sabrina Marie is played by Jazz Sinclair
who too showed up in that Series so a
high school reunion now there's kids
sliding along a hallway and you might
notice some snow to the left and right
I'm guessing that this is an Iceman type
character and he's also holding a beer
Iceman and X2 chilled Wolverine's beer
so it could be a nod to that he was also
played by Sean Ashmore who played
Lamplighter and a you have to admit it
is all connected now there's some
pancakes with a smiley face on them
showing Pancake Man say you're shaking
your head now but wait till we get to
the puppet Theory now we then have Marie
shooting veins out of her hands and this
happens in a kitchen that we let us get
smashed up guessing that the person she
grabbed was attacking the family we see
here and she stepped in in order to take
them out it's possible that his powers
were maturing and he decided to kill his
family or they just let rip the Red
River episode in diabolical had the
students going back to their parents to
murder them for what they'd done and it
could be a similar thing happening here
the kitchen has a number of bites in it
that pop up in the trailer so expect to
see this as one of the big action scenes
we then see chance badermo bursting at
his powers and by the looks of it the
characters telekinetic there's also
Marie being chased along the corridor
some of the kids showing off their
abilities and an Ant-Man type character
getting trapped under a plastic cup
better than what they did in season
three I tell you I still haven't got
that out my brain and we also see
someone trapped in what I think is Red
River before we cut to Marie being
interviewed this is clearly promoting
the university and it's another part of
world PR that makes them seem like
Heroes instead of what they are we can
catch a homelander statue here as well
showing how the character looks over
everything this then leads into a lot of
bloodshots and what people have assumed
is the Deep puppet popping up again this
puppet also gets its head ripped off at
one point and we see deep on the Sesame
Street parody called Avenue B like for
bought now if you look at the puppet
here it has stubble whereas later on the
graffiti cardo one doesn't due to it
also getting its head ripped off and
there being a spine I actually believe
this is an actual person rather than
being a puppet if we look at the head
ripping scene this puppet is actually
grabbed by another puppet and rips this
puppet's Scar from its body therefore
there might be several puppet characters
that are buying it out for the top spot
and I'd love it if the Deep puppet was
just as toxic as he is puppets also work
as a metaphor as all of the students in
staff of V are of course puppets for the
organization really nice thing you might
not catch and that ends the teaser we
will not want a high note there let's be
fair now oh I I can't wait for the show
and yeah this trailer was kind of a
sleeper hit over the weekend but it's
really got me interested to see what's
coming down the line I'm really sorry
it's taken this long to get to it but I
hope you enjoyed the breakdown and
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on it where it ain't comedy Edition
right now and giving away three copies
of House of the Dragon season one on the
15th of December and all you have to do
to be on the chance of winning is like
the video make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the teaser
you pick the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one are on screen right now so
that's you then message me on Twitter at
heavy spoilers you want some else to
watch then make sure you check out our
Brighton of the Transformers trailer
which will be linked on screen right now
lots of cool at least directs and plot
details and that and definitely head
over there right after this by the way
thanks for singing through the video
I've been Paul I'll see you next time
take care peace